mode is the number that occurs the most.
in this case,
our mode is the number 8 as occurs twice,
or as all other numbers only occur once.
median is our middle value.
our first step is to arrange our list in order
by smallest to largest
or largest to smallest.
I wanna go smallest to largest.
I now simply cross off the smallest
on the left hand side with my largest
on the right hand side
and I repeat this process until I'm left only one value
in the middle.
as I had an even number of values.
I had one, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
I'm gonna end up with 2 values in the middle.
therefore, to find the meeting,
I simply take the average of the 2 numbers
in the middle.
in this case,
I add them together and divide by 2,
7 at 8 gives us 15
and 15รท2 gives us 7.5
to find the mean also commonly
referred to as the average I start by adding up all my
values and I divide by a number of values
here I've got one 2 3 4 5 6 so I divide the answer by 6
adding up all my values that comes to a total of 39
and I'm going to 5 by 6
as I got 6 values or 39รท6 will give a 6.5
the range is the highest value subtract the lowest
value in this case our highest value is number 12
subtract the lowest value,
which in this case is one
and 12 subtract one
gives us 11.